Der Rasenfunk Kurzpass. 30 Spieltage sind absolviert in der 2. Männer Bundesliga. So langsam spitzt sich alles zu. Sowohl im Aufstiegskampf als auch im Abstiegskampf. Beides wollen wir besprechen hier im Rasenfunk. Ich begrüße euch ganz herzlich hier in diesem Rasenfunk Kurzpass Nr. 202. Mein Name ist Max Jakob Ost. Ich bin der Ed Genetzer auf Twitter und ich freue mich, zwei Gäste hier zu haben, die auch einen Schwerpunkt mitgebracht haben. Meine Güte, da geht es schon gut los. Zum einen Dominik Slišković von T-Online, der Ed, Jasam, Dominik auf Twitter. Hallo Dominik, schön, dass du mal wieder hier bist. Ja, freut mich, dass du hier bist. Mit dir werden wir gleich ein bisschen ausführlicher über den FC Schalke 04 sprechen. Wir haben schon vorab geklärt, du hast eine gute Laune mitgebracht in diese Sendung.
Ich würde an der Stelle ganz gerne einhaken, weil ihr habt jetzt ganz gut den Kader skizziert und so auch ein bisschen den Saisonverlauf. Ich erinnere mich, dass wir hier im Herbst irgendwann über den HSV gesprochen haben. Und da haben wir darüber gesprochen, dass angeblich der Stuhl von Walther schon gewackelt habe, aber Jonas Beuth dann ausgegeben hat, Saisonziel ist die Entwicklung. Es geht nicht mehr um den Ausstieg an sich, sondern um eine Wertentwicklung. Denn der HSV könne nicht mehr fertige Spieler kaufen. Und als wir da jetzt vorhin darüber gesprochen haben über dieses immer wiederkehrende Phänomen des Einbrechens im Frühjahr, da habe ich mich zurückerinnert, wie das auch die einzelnen Trainer erlebt haben. Denn das gehört ja zum HSV dazu, dass es eben schon sehr viele unterschiedliche Trainer gab. Also Tune im letzten Jahr, Dieter Hecking davor, Hannes Wolf hast du vorhin auch schon genannt. Und wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, dann war das bei allen Trainern so, dass sie zu Beginn der Rückrunde und dann auch, wenn die ersten Rückschläge kamen, im Februar, März gesagt haben, ja, das kriegen wir schon hin, das wird alles easy, wir müssen jetzt ruhig bleiben. Und dann am Ende waren sie doch davon überrascht, welche Wucht diese Dynamik aufgenommen hat, dass man eben dann doch es einfach gesagt vergeigt mit dem Aufstieg, ohne dass ich das jetzt... Ja, das hört sich zu salopp an, also ich mein's jetzt nicht abwertend, aber es hat eben einfach nicht geklappt. Meinst du, das wäre eine entscheidende Stellschraube, dass man vielleicht einem Trainer mal eine zweite Saison gibt, dass er auch diese Dynamik schon kennt? Glaubst du, Tim Walter könnte dieser Trainer sein?
Also ich bin der Meinung, dass man an Tim Walter festhalten sollte. Auch da erlebe ich gemischte oder höre ich gemischte Stimmen. Auch aus meinem bekannten Kreis und auch, ja, was HSV-Fans allgemein angeht. Man muss ja auch mittlerweile sagen, wir haben jetzt so oft den Trainer gewechselt. Alles, was wir oder das Einzige, was wir noch nicht versucht haben, ist, mal mit dem Trainer in die zweite Saison zu gehen. Deswegen kann man ja schon sagen, okay, neuer Trainer wäre genauso mutig. Warum gehen wir jetzt nicht mal den mutigen Schritt und behalten ihn einfach mal? Und ich würde es halt aber auch bei Tim Walther davon abhängig machen, dass man auch weiter schaut und an dem Konzept, was man jetzt eigentlich die Saison gemacht hat, auch so mit Spieler aus der eigenen Jugend heranzuführen bzw. allgemein auf eine junge Mannschaft zu setzen. Weil auch der HSV hatte ja teilweise ganz junge Spieler auf dem Platz gehabt. Also ich kann jetzt leider nicht nachgucken, aber der HSV hat keinen Spieler, der 30 Jahre ist oder älter. Ich glaube, Heuer Fernandes und Kittel sind mit 29 die ältesten Spieler im Kader. Und dass man einfach diesen Weg quasi beibehält, wobei man da natürlich auch sagen muss, dass wenn man jetzt an ihm festhält, dann muss da auch ein gewisser Erfolg schon zu Saisonbeginn zu sehen sein. Also man könnte sich das dann nicht leisten, quasi jetzt zu sagen, okay, wir bleiben oder behalten Walter und schauen dann mal, ob das dann irgendwann in der nächsten Saison besser wird.
Aber glaubt ihr denn, er würde passen von der Art des Spielens und auch von der Art, wie er mit dem Umfeld umgeht?
Ich finde schon. Also er gibt auch vielen Fans das Gefühl, dass er auch gerne hier ist. Natürlich muss man natürlich auch mal sehen, die Leute wollen sich auch immer von ihrer besten Seite zeigen. Und es lief ja auch lange genug gut bei uns. Da gab es ja auch quasi keinen Grund, ja, nicht seine beste Seite zu zeigen oder halt an seiner positiven Ausstrahlung zu zweifeln. Aber der Spielstil, den wir haben, grundsätzlich gefällt glaube ich vielen. Ich habe von vielen gehört dieses Jahr, die meinen, es macht viel mehr Spaß, dieses Jahr HSV-Spiele zu sehen als in den Saisons davor. Auch gerade mit diesem mutigen Spielaufbau. Und ja, man spielt sich ja wirklich viele Chancen heraus in den meisten Spielen. Und ja, der Weg auch mit den jungen Spielern, der gefällt eigentlich schon vielen. Es ist halt immer nur die Frage, wie getrieben ist der Verein oder auch die einzelnen Fans immer von dem Aufstieg. Es gibt ja auch genug Leute, die sagen, man könnte, oder man sollte jetzt erst mal dieses Jahr gar nicht aufsteigen und sich weiter festigen und dann im nächsten Jahr aufsteigen. Also diese Meinung gibt es auch unter HSV-Fans. Ich habe aber auch das Gefühl, dass es halt auch von den Medien und dem Umfeld auch gar nicht akzeptiert wird. Also ich kenne das wie gesagt selber auch. Wenn ich zum Beispiel gefragt werde jeden Tag, ja, oder nach jedem Spiel steigt der HSV auf und ich sage nein, ich glaube nicht, dann sind alle direkt geschockt. So nach dem Motto, wie kannst du nur sagen, dass der Verein nicht aufsteigt? Und manchmal habe ich das Gefühl, dass von außen die Leute einem auch viel mehr oder auch dem HSV viel mehr dieses, ihr müsst aufsteigen, aufzwingen wollen, als man es vielleicht auch selber teilweise sagt. Also es ist ganz schwierig, wie ich auch gesagt habe, bei St. Pauli gibt es gefühlt wenig Druck. Das ist beim HSV halt ganz anders. Es ist ja auch bei Schalke so, wenn jetzt Werder dreimal in Folge 1.1 gespielt, das kriegen viele gar nicht so mit. Auf Schalke würde jetzt wieder oder jetzt hier beim HSV, würde das Thema, würde das in den Medien wieder ganz anders aufgefasst werden. Da würde wieder geredet werden von, schaffen sie es dieses Jahr wieder nicht, haben sie wieder Angst. Ich finde, Walter wäre auf jeden Fall jetzt mal ein Trainer, an dem man festhalten kann, dem man eine zweite Chance geben sollte. Auch im Pokal läuft das ja sehr, sehr gut dieses Jahr. Das wäre vielleicht mal der Schritt, der vielleicht wirklich der mutigste beim HSV wäre, wenn man sagt, wir ändern den Weg jetzt nicht, sondern wir versuchen es jetzt im zweiten Anlauf unter ihm.
Damit hast du ja schon die Brücke gebaut zum letzten Thema, das wir unbedingt noch ansprechen müssen. Wir nehmen jetzt am Oster Montag auf. Das heißt, morgen Abend, am Dienstagabend, wirst du irgendwann wissen, ob der HSV es geschafft hat, ins DFB-Pokalfinale einzuziehen. Man ist in diesem Wettbewerb nach einem 2 zu 1 in Braunschweig in jeder Runde über Elfmeterschießen weitergekommen. Also würde es einen jetzt auch nicht komplett aus den Socken hauen, wenn es jetzt wieder bis ins Elfmeterschießen ging. Man hat bisher gegen Braunschweig, Nürnberg, Köln und Karlsruhe jeweils gewonnen. Jetzt kommt der SC Freiburg. Ich glaube, was emotional dieses Spiel bedeutet, das ist allen klar. Der letzte Titel des HSV liegt schon so weit zurück, dass ich es gerade nicht im Kopf ausrechnen kann. 25 Jahre, nein, 35 Jahre, 1987 war das der DFB-Pokal. Welche Bedeutung hat denn dieses Spiel aus finanzieller Sicht? Weiß man darüber auch was?
Ja, aus finanzieller Sicht ist das Spiel sehr, sehr, sehr wichtig. Wir haben ja auch gesehen, nachdem wir quasi in die Zeitfinale eingezogen sind, dass man direkt danach auch den Transfer von Vuzković quasi fixiert hat. Der war ja vorher auch ausgeliehen mit einer Kaufoption beziehungsweise Kaufpflicht dann bei Aufstieg, wo man jetzt aber dem Vernehmen nach sich bei einer niedrigeren Ablöse geeinigt hat, weil auch Split das Geld lieber vorher haben wollte als später. Und Muhaym, der Ersatz von Leibold ist, der ja schon quasi die Hälfte der Saison ausfällt, den haben wir auch verpflichtet, kurz nachdem wir den Halbfinaleinzug geschafft haben. Also da merkt man richtig, dass allein schon das Preisgeld uns sehr, sehr gut tut und auch für die weitere Planung sehr wichtig ist. Aber grundsätzlich, glaube ich, hat hier jeder, wenn nicht gerade Jonas Boldt ist, nicht den finanziellen Aspekt vor Augen, sondern einfach diesen Traum, dass man einmal nach Berlin fahren darf mit seinem Verein. Seit Wochen oder quasi seit der Auslosung sind, soweit ich weiß, alle HSV-Fans heiß auf dieses Spiel morgen. Und viele haben auch große Hoffnungen und sind zuversichtlich.
Warum auch nicht ist alles möglich in einem Spiel. Man hat es bisher in allen anderen Partien auch hinbekommen. Egal wie es gelaufen ist, Doppelkontakt. Florian Kainz im Elfmeterschießen vom 1. Auch wenn du mich jetzt indirekt als Jonas Beuth bezeichnet hast, weil ich nach den Finanzen gefragt habe. Aber sag gerne noch ein paar Worte dazu. Der HSV, er hat ja eine große Tradition. Und die ist ja auch nicht erfolglos. Auch wenn ich jetzt den letzten Titel zitiert habe, der lange zurückliegt, aber man war ja auch Teilnehmer im UEFA Cup und sogar in der Europa League 2009, 2010 war man noch mit dabei. Das ist ja wiederum erst 13 Jahre her. Glaubst du, das könnte ja auch so eine Initialzündung sein, mal wieder einen Erfolg mit diesem Verein erlebt zu haben, dass vielleicht auch man nicht immer nur an die verpassten Aufstiege denkt, wenn man jetzt an die letzten Jahre zurückdenkt?
Ja, ob es eine Initialzündung ist oder sein kann, das wäre mir zu schwer, das quasi so einordnen zu können. Aber der Einzug ins Finale, das wäre auch für viele hier in Hamburg bzw. die auch dem HSV die Daumen drücken, auch einfach so eine Art Genugtuung. Wie ich ja schon gesagt habe, man hat immer ein bisschen die Versagensangst am Ende seit Jahren. Und das wäre jetzt mal so ein wichtiges Spiel, wo man sagen kann, wenn wir das gegen den SC Freiburg gewinnen und auch noch ins Finale einziehen, gegen wen dann auch immer dieses Spiel dann stattfinden würde. Das wäre halt einfach, dass man diese letzte Hürde, an der man quasi die letzten Jahre auch im Aufstiegskampf immer gescheitert ist, hätte man die schon mal überwunden. Und dann das Finale wäre dann halt nur noch quasi die Zugabe. Da muss man ja fast schon ausgehen, gegen Leipzig spielen zu müssen. Da kann man sich die Chancen dann auch nochmal ausrechnen. Aber ja, ich glaube, es würde mir zu weit gehen, zu sagen, es wäre eine Initialzündung für die nächsten Jahre. Aber es wäre auf jeden Fall für die Fernsehle sehr erfrischend und finanziell natürlich auch.
Ja, das muss man ja eigentlich jedem Fan eines solchen Vereins wie des HSVs sehr wünschen, weil man da eben nicht nur sportliche Misere erlebt hat, sondern das Ganze eben auch unter dem Brennglas der Öffentlichkeit. Das ist einfach der Unterschied zu vielen anderen Vereinen, ich glaube sogar zu solchen wie dem 1. FC Kaiserslautern, wobei es sein kann, dass ich da jetzt dann auch verdränge, weil ich das nicht mehr so mitbekomme, weil die jetzt bis in die 3. Liga runtergereicht wurden. Aber die letzten Jahre als HSV-Fan, die waren nicht einfach. Ich habe das immer indirekt gespürt, wenn sich Menschen bei mir beschwert haben, weil sie mir unterstellt haben, ich würde den HSV nicht mögen, ich mag nur die Formmusik nicht, ansonsten habe ich überhaupt keine Probleme mit diesem Verein. Die ist wirklich ganz, ganz hervorragend. Das ist das Einzige, wo ich dem HSV etwas missgönne, wenn sie einen Tor geschossen haben, denke ich mir, muss ich jetzt wieder diesen Mist hören. Aber wir werden es sehen. Ich wünsche dir auf jeden Fall, dass du es irgendwie genießen kannst, dieses Spiel. Auch wenn ich weiß, dass man da immer so angespannt ist, dass das sehr schwierig ist. Damit beschließen wir den Aufstiegspart. Eigentlich wollten wir noch über den FC Heidenheim sprechen, aber die haben sich selber rausgenommen aus diesem Segment. Und diese Sendung wird sowieso schon lang genug haben. 0 zu 2 verloren zu Hause gegen Aue. Damit ist Heidenheim raus. Die haben jetzt 8 Punkte Rückstand auf den Relegationsplatz. Das wird nichts mehr werden. Deshalb lasst noch schnell in ein paar Worten über den Abstiegskampf sprechen. Da hat einer von euch beiden, ich weiß gerade gar nicht mehr, ob es du warst, Dominik, gesagt, dass Düsseldorf ja jetzt auch mit Etion sich stabilisiert hat, da rausgekommen ist. Zwar gab es nur in Anführungszeichen ein Unentschieden bei Hannover 96 in Überzahl. An diesem Samstag aber, man kann in der Tat sagen, bei acht Punkten Vorsprung auf den Relikationsplatz scheint es so zu sein, als hätte sich die Fortuna gerettet.
Ja, also ich meine, Tune hat, also ich glaube, auch einfach die ganze Mannschaft stabilisiert. Nicht nur was punktemäßig jetzt, also die Punkte angeht und den Tabellenplatz, aber hat einfach auch nochmal irgendwie die Spieler neu erreicht und eine Aufbruchsstimmung geschaffen. Ich meine, Tune war ja sowohl in Osnabrück als auch in Hamburg, auch wenn Tobi das wahrscheinlich nicht so gerne hören möchte, durchaus erfolgreicher Trainer. Dass es jetzt in Hamburg nicht mit dem Aufstieg geklappt hat, ist natürlich ärgerlich oder schade, je nachdem. Aber auch wenn man sich jetzt anschaut, Düsseldorf ist ja von den ganzen Teams, die unten drin sind, die einzige Mannschaft, die ein positives Torverhältnis hat. Das spricht ja eigentlich auch für die Stabilität dieser ganzen Mannschaft. Und von daher kann man, glaube ich, schon mal Glückwünsche an Daniel Thun und die Fortuna-Senden für den Klassenerhalt.
Tobi, wie blickst du auf den Erfolg von Thun bei Düsseldorf? Würdest du dir da manchmal wünschen, dass man da vielleicht sich nicht getrennt hätte voneinander?
Ja, den Wunsch hatte ich natürlich, weil das ausgesagt hätte, dass wir wahrscheinlich aufgestiegen wären, wenn man sich nicht getrennt hätte. Als ich die Nachricht gelesen habe, dass Daniel Thun bei Düsseldorf unterschrieben wird oder unterschrieben hat, war mir eigentlich klar, dass die sich sehr schnell retten werden. Das ist auch ein sehr guter Trainer, da kann ich auch zustimmen. Der vermittelt ja auch eine gewisse Ruhe. Das hat mir bei uns auch gut gefallen. Wie er auch einfach mit der gesamten Situation umgegangen ist. Das ist ja teilweise wie in so einem College-Film. Da kommt die Tune vor, wie der Basketballtrainer, der mit den schwierigsten Typen zurechtkommt und die auf die richtige Straße bringt. Das ist ein Trainer, dem würde ich zutrauen, jeden Verein quasi in der Liga zu halten. Der Düsseldorf-Kader hat auch eine gewisse Qualität, die er mir in der Saison eher unterperformt. Ich hatte sie sogar vor der Saison auf Platz 1 mutig getippt. Muss ich zugeben, was mittlerweile unangenehm ist, zuzugeben. Aber für mich war mit der Verpflichtung von Tune Düsseldorf quasi aus dem Abstiegskampf raus.
Na, dann hat sich das ja so bewahrheitet. Und das könnte sogar sein, ich bin mir gerade nicht genau sicher, dass ich vor Tune Düsseldorf auch sehr gut hatte. Nee, bei mir war es der 1. FC Nürnberg und Paderborn, die ich als Außenseiter vornehin getippt habe. Ja, aber meine Tippkünste in dieser Saison. Da bereiten wir den Mantel des Schweigens darüber und reden lieber über Hannover 96. 7 Punkte vorm Relegationsplatz. Da war es jetzt, glaube ich, sehr wichtig, Tobi, jetzt dieses Spiel in Unterzahl, das ich gerade angesprochen habe, gegen Düsseldorf nicht zu verlieren. Und damit dann wahrscheinlich auch den Klassenerhalt zu sichern. Oder hast du da ein Fragezeichen?
Nee, da habe ich gar kein Fragezeichen mehr. Was aber auch gar nicht unbedingt an der Qualität von Hannover liegt, sondern eher an der sehr schlechten Rückrunde von Dynamo Dresden. Die wir in der gesamten Rückrunde nur 7 Punkte geholt haben. Und jetzt sehe ich nicht, wie die die 7 Punkte auf Hannover noch in 4 Spielen aufholen sollen. Aber ja, Hannover ist auch so ein Verein, der eigentlich meiner Meinung nach mehr Perspektive hat als das, was sie quasi in den letzten Jahren jedes Mal auf dem Platz bringen können.
Also ich finde, Hannover ist irgendwie absolut durchschnittlich. Auch im Kader besetzt. Also ich würde eigentlich von der ganzen Mannschaft nur Ron-Robert Zieler rausgreifen. Das auch fast nur auf der Basis der beiden Spiele gegen Schalke, wo er wirklich Hannover im Spiel gehalten hat. Mir fehlt irgendwie bei Hannover grundsätzlich so ein gewisser Zauber, der diesen Verein interessant macht. Wahrscheinlich auch für Spieler von außerhalb. Zum Beispiel der Dimas, den sie ausgeliehen haben aus Feyenoord. Er hat gesagt, er will gerne im Ausland bleiben, aber nicht wirklich bei Hannover. Hannover-Fans hören wahrscheinlich auch nicht gerne. Von daher kann man Hannover eigentlich nur wünschen, dass die sich im Sommer hinsetzen und schauen, wie sie diese Mannschaft und diese Marke wieder interessant machen. Aber ich glaube, das wird nicht in der 3. Liga passieren müssen. Dafür ist der Abstand auf Dresden einfach zu groß.
Da würde ich mich gerne noch mal korrigieren von eben. Ich wollte jetzt auch nicht den Eindruck vermitteln, dass ich Hannover jetzt grundsätzlich irgendwo auf den ersten sechs Tabellen-Rängen sehe in der 2. Liga. Aber ich denke schon, dass grundsätzlich bei Hannover das Potenzial da ist, dass du jede Saison zumindestens Platz 8, 9, 10 erreichen musst. Also ich sehe eigentlich nicht, wie man bei der Konkurrenz teilweise in der 2. Liga so vom Gesamtkonstrukt unbedingt in den Abstiegskampf geraten müsste. Aber ja, da muss ich auch Dominik ein bisschen recht geben. Um Hannover weht echt so ein bisschen der Winddurchschnitt. Man wird diesen Gedanken quasi nicht los, selbst wenn sie mal eine etwas bessere Saison haben.
Auch wenn man sich anschaut, dass man so die... Ich wollte nur hinzufügen mit Durchschnitt. Also diese ganze Saison spiegelt Durchschnitt wieder. Also neun Siege, neun Unentschieden und dann halt die 12 Niederlagen. Aber es ist halt... Also Platz acht bis zehn, was du vorhin angesprochen hast, ist auch das, wo ich Hannover vor der Saison am ehesten gesehen hätte. Dementsprechend ist man schon überrascht, dass sie sich doch so tief wiederfinden in der Tabelle. Aber wie gesagt, wenn ich mir den Kader anschaue und auch das Spiel unter Dambrofsky, seitdem er da ist, das ist halt alles so... Das schreit halt so 0011. Klar, jetzt dieses 00 gegen Düsseldorf, das war ein Ausrufezeichen, wenn man so lange in Unterzahl war. Aber es gäbe sicherlich auch Mannschaften, die irgendwie dann zumindest nochmal den Willen gezeigt hätten, so jetzt zeigen wir es dem Gegner aber so richtig und holen uns sogar den Sieg im eigenen Stadion in Unterzahl. Und das Gefühl hatte ich bei dem Spiel überhaupt nicht. Ich war schon sehr darauf bedacht, komm, ein Punkt ist immer ein Einpunkt, der wird irgendwie für den Klassenerhalt reichen, dann schaut man halt nächstes Jahr weiter.
Ja, ich finde auch, über dem Verein schwebt auch so mit Martin Kind so eine dunkle Wolke, also ich kenne niemanden, der irgendwie positive Worte über ihn findet. Man hat ja auch das Gefühl, dass er teilweise......kennst also keine Vegetarierin. Ja, manchmal habe ich das Gefühl, und das von anderen auch schon gehört, dass er fast schon gegen den Verein arbeitet. Da kommen ja manchmal auch Aussagen, wo man sich echt fragt, wie kannst du das jetzt sagen in dieser Position über deinen eigenen Verein? Und wenn man sich jetzt auch seit Wochen, oder seitdem Zuschauer auch wieder da sein dürfen, sich dann mal in einer Konferenz das Hannover-Spiel anguckt, wie wenig Zuschauer da sind. Also, das versprüht alles auch wenig. Ja, Positives, sag ich mal, was so im Moment um den Club herum passiert. Zumindest war ein Eindruck von außen.
Ja, ehrlich gesagt habe ich dieses Gefühl auch. Also ihr nennt es den Hauch des Mittelmaßes. Ich rieche da schon einen leichten Verwesungsgeruch. Ich hoffe allerdings, dass ich mich da täusche. Also Hannover 96 immerhin scheint es mit dem Klassenerhalt zu passen. Und das trifft auch auf den SV Sandhausen zu. Und das liegt daran, dass Sandhausen quasi die umgekehrte Dynamo-Dresden-Rückrunde spielt. In der Rückrundentabelle liegt der SV Sandhausen auf Rang 4, hat nur 2x verloren. Einzig und allein Werder Bremen und Schalke 04 sind da besser oder gleich gut. Also absolut fantastische Rückrunde. 21 Punkte von 35 stand heute, hat Sandhausen in der Rückrunde geholt. Dominik, wir haben vorhin schon immer mal wieder über Sandhausen gesprochen. Unter anderem, weil sie es eben schaffen, dass die Großen bei ihnen Punkte liegen lassen. Man hat jetzt nur die besagten 2x verloren. Einmal mit 0 zu 1 gegen Rostock war das, glaube ich, und das andere war gegen Regensburg ein deutliches 0 zu 3. Was macht denn Sandhausen so stark, dass man eben so wenige... Man hat viele Unentschieden, aber man verliert eben einfach nicht. Warum kann man die nicht brechen?
Ich glaube, Sandhausen ist ja über die letzten Jahre auch der Inberift der 2. Liga geworden. Also eher so dieser Club musste in der 2. Liga sein. Aber ich muss sagen, ich finde, das ist genau das, was so ein Club ist, den ich in der 2. Liga auch sehen möchte. Das ist halt so SSV Reutlingen, FC Schweinfurt, LRA-Vibes, auch dieses ganze Stadion mit den verschiedenen Tribünen und so. Das macht irgendwie schon Bock. Und wenn man sich auch den Kader anschaut, der schon ziemlich klug zusammengestellt ist. Also man hat irgendwie Seufert und Sucu, die ja Erstliga-Erfahrungen haben mit Bielefeld. Man hat einen Testrot, der immer quasi zweistellig treffen kann im Laufe der Saison. Man hat Diekmeier als absoluten Führungsspieler, der auch, wenn man als Stürmer auf ihn zuläuft, was hermacht. Von daher glaube ich, dass viele Mannschaften nach Sandhausen reisen und denken, die drei Punkte haben wir sicher. Dann doch auf eine sehr kompakte, eingespielte Mannschaft treffen, die ganz genau wissen, wo ihr Platz ist. Das ist das untere Tabellendrittel, aber es ist das untere Tabellendrittel, das im Zweifelsfall nichts mit dem Abstieg zu tun hat. Das ist auch etwas, was der Verein über die Jahre kultiviert hat, was auch Alois Schwarz vielleicht dem einen oder anderen Spieler mitgegeben hat. Das ist einfach dieses Underdog-Gefühl. Ab in der Rückrunde reitet man auf dieser Welle. Ohne dass ich jetzt großartige Sympathien oder Verbindungen zum SV Sandhausen habe, aber ich muss schon sagen, wenn der Klub drin bleibt, nehme ich das mit Wohlwollen hin.
Da werden sie erleichtert aufatmen in Sandhausen. Tobi, hast du noch etwas zu ergänzen?
Wenig. Also ich wurde jetzt quasi schon perfekt zusammengefasst, was Sandhausen ausmacht. Also ja, sie sind einfach so der große Underdog der Liga. Und ich habe auch das Gefühl, das wird sich auch die nächsten Jahre nicht ändern. Aber was halt wirklich ganz wichtig ist, ist, dass die, wie Dominik schon gesagt hat, sie wissen einfach, wo ihr Platz ist. Da wird nicht groß geträumt und nicht groß erzählt. Da wird halt einfach gesagt, okay, wir tun jetzt alles daran, dass wir quasi alle großen Teams ärgern und dass wir gegen die Kleinen noch die wichtigen Punkte mitnehmen. Und dann wird da mit höchstem Einsatz und großem Willen das einfach alles untergeordnet. Und dann bleiben sie jedes Jahr drin. Und ich kann mich ja auch als HSV-Fan auch noch gut daran erinnern, dass die zu uns am 34. Spieltag in Volkspark kamen. Uns hätte ein Punkt gereicht und die gewinnen 5-1. Und für die die Party des Jahres, weil die sich sagen, boah, wir haben dem HSV das Bein gestellt. Und so ist auch das Gefühl, dass sie auch spielen, wenn sie auch die großen Teams gerade bei sich zu Hause haben. Da wissen sie auch, okay, es ist unangenehm, in Sandhausen zu spielen. Fühlt sich dann teilweise fast schon an, wie so ein DFB-Pokal-Spiel in der ersten Runde. Wenn man dann noch das Stadion vergleicht mit vielen anderen in der Liga. Also ja, die holen aus ihren Mitteln das Beste heraus. Also kann man eigentlich nur den Hut vorziehen.
Dann machen wir das an der Stelle auch. Und als Letztes habe ich da nur noch ein Quiz für euch. Tobi, du darfst dich daran versuchen. Was war am 12. Dezember des letzten Jahres?
Dezember.
Wir sind im Segment von Dynamo Dresden. Soll ich auflösen?
Der letzte Heimsieg?
Der letzte Sieg sogar. Es war der letzte Sieg. Das war am 17. Spieltag, 12. Dezember. Seitdem nur unentschieden oder verloren. Sieben Punkte geholt, da kann man sich auch ausrechnen. Also es waren sieben unentschieden. Und das ist eben der Grund, warum wir, anders als im Ausstiegskampf, im Abstiegskampf kaum noch Spannung haben. Sechs Punkte Rückstand hat Dresden schon. Man hat zwischendurch den Trainer gewechselt. Alexander Schmidt stand schon nach der Niederlage gegen Kiel zur Debatte. Ist durchaus umstritten gewesen. Nach einem 0-1 zu Hause gegen Darmstadt musste er dann gehen. Neuer Trainer wurde Gerino Capretti, vorher Trainer beim SC Valle. Tobi, kannst du mir erklären, warum so wenig auch mit diesem Trainerwechsel geklappt hat? Das Restprogramm war natürlich dann brutal. Also Capretti durfte gleich bei Werder ran gegen St. Pauli, gegen den 1. FC Nürnberg, Schalke 04. Eigentlich wäre jetzt mit Sandhausen und Kiel die Zeit gewesen, wo man vielleicht hätte anfangen müssen, Punkte zusammen. Aber irgendwie klappt es nicht bei Dresden.
Ja, so wirklich erklären kann ich mir das ehrlich gesagt auch nicht. Vor allem, ich habe einige Spiele gesehen, auch jetzt hier in der Rückrunde. Ich finde, in Bremen waren sie erstaunlich gut, haben dann halt verloren dort. Gegen St. Pauli zu Hause waren sie auch lange gut. Auch gegen den HSV zu Hause. Also die Spiele, die ich gesehen habe, waren auch gar nicht so schlecht. Deswegen war ich auch vor 2-3 Wochen selbst ein bisschen überrascht, als ich geguckt habe, ok, Dresden hat ja quasi gar nichts gewonnen. Oder hat halt auch nichts gewonnen in der Rückrunde. Ja, ganz schwierig. Ja, so wirklich erklären muss ich ehrlich sagen, kann ich das nicht.
Das ist ja auch in Ordnung, musst du ja nicht alles wissen. Vielleicht kann Dominik uns weiterhelfen. Wie ist dein Eindruck von Dynamo?
Ich muss sagen, ich finde Dynamo zeigt sich eigentlich unter Capretti schon spielerisch verbessert, aber es reicht dann halt immer nicht zum Sieg. Also Tobi hat das 1 zu 2 gegen Werder angesprochen, es gab ja auch ein 1 zu 2 gegen Schalke. Das sind halt alles knappe Ergebnisse. Also es fehlt gefühlt nicht viel zu einem Sieg, aber es fehlt halt immer was. Und ich frage mich, gerade mit Blick auf Capretti, ob es dann halt nicht irgendwie am Spielermaterial hapert. Capretti ist ja jemand, der für sehr hohes Anlaufen, für viel Intensität steht, für schnelles Umschaltspiel, für den vertikalen Ball statt den diagonalen. Also was der aus Pferl gemacht hat, ist auch aller Ehre wert. Und war auch ein Trainer, den ich, bevor er dann bei Dresden gelandet ist und bevor das auf Schalke mit Ramozes dahingegangen ist und ich dann eher von einer weiteren Zweitliga gesungen geträumt habe. Das war auf jeden Fall ein Typ, den ich auf der Liste hatte als möglichen Schalke-Zweitligatrainer, weil er einfach so einen klaren Plan hat. Und ich finde, man sieht diesen klaren Plan durchaus, aber es fehlt halt einfach dann immer irgendwie an dem Quäntchen. Und wahrscheinlich ist es dann einfach auch dieses negative Momentum, die die Psyche, dass man da halt dann einfach kein Erfolgserlebnis hat und dann eben dann auch so abrutscht. Also ich meine, weil bei Dresden geht es ja eigentlich nur noch darum, diesen Relegationsplatz zu halten, beziehungsweise, ja, also eigentlich ist man ja sogar festsementiert, mehr oder weniger auf Platz 16. Dann wird es halt spannend, weil Capretti ja auch nur ein, für die 2. Liga gültigen Vertrag hat. Also ob man sich dann dann nochmal zusammensetzt und sagt, naja, jetzt geht man doch in die 3. Liga mit ihm, weil er ist auf jeden Fall ein Trainer, der hohe Ambitionen hat. Und ich finde, der Schritt von ihm zu Dresden war auch klug gewählt. Also auf jeden Fall eine Liga höher, ein Club mit viel Tradition. Was ganz anderes als fair. Und ich habe jetzt so ein bisschen die Angst, dass er so der nächste Atterlei wird, der damals auch mit Lotte Ähnliches geschaffen hat und dann bei Bochum irgendwie gegen die Wand gefahren ist und seitdem im Profifußball keinen Nachweis mehr abgeben konnte. Und die Befürchtung habe ich bei Capretti auch, es wäre schade um ihn. Dementsprechend hoffe ich für Capretti, dass das doch noch klappt mit dem Klassenerhalt dann in der Relegation.
Letztlich ist es jetzt alles eine lange Vorbereitung auf die Relegation, obwohl Aue jetzt gewinnen konnte. Am Wochenende sind es immer noch sieben Punkte Vorsprung, die Dynamo Dresden hat bei noch vier ausstehenden Spielen. Wahrscheinlich wird es nur um diese zwei Spiele gehen gegen den Relegationsteilnehmer aus der 3. Liga. Da streiten sich allem anscheinend nach der 1. FC Kaiserslautern und Eintracht Braunschweig um diesen Platz, wobei da noch ein bisschen mehr zu spielen ist als in der 2. Liga. Also schauen wir uns das an. Da könnte ja ein Vorteil sein, dass er diese Liga mit Fahl ja auch schon ein bisschen beschnuppern durfte. Ihr zwei, das war ein sehr langer Kurzpass. Wir haben sogar meine großzügig gerechnete Zeit ein bisschen überschritten. Umso mehr danke ich euch beiden für eure Zeit, die ihr euch genommen habt. Und es gab ja auch wirklich einfach viel zu erzählen bei eurer beiden Vereine. Zum einen danke ich Dominik Slišković von T-Online, der Ad, JasamDominik, auf Twitter. Danke dir und ich bin gespannt, ob wir uns das nächste Mal vielleicht in einem Erstliga-Rasenfunk wiederhören.
Vielen Dank, Max, für die Einladung. Hat großen Spaß gemacht und Glück auf. Und dann hoffentlich nächstes Jahr in der 1.
Wir werden es genau beobachten. Und ebenso danke ich Tobias Kröger von transfermarkt.de, der Ad Tobias Kröger. Danke dir, Tobi, dass du mal wieder mit dabei warst und viel Spaß beim DFB-Pokal-Halbfinale. Und euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Das war Rasenfunk Kurzpass Nr. 202. Der Rasenfunk ist paywall, werbe- und sponsorenfrei. Wenn ihr uns unterstützen wollt, dann tut das bitte auf rasenfunk.de slash-supporters-club. Auch unsere Gäste profitieren davon. Sie bekommen ein kleines Honorar. Herzlichen Dank, wenn ihr das tun wollt. Ansonsten gibt es auf kiosk.rasenfunk.de noch eine schicke neue Rasenfunktasse. Und dann hören wir uns bald wieder hier an dieser Stelle. Bis dahin, bleibt gesund und macht es gut.